foreign
[Music]
stand up
you see you you have an adhesion on this
arm okay
so you don't need to fumble here but you
can't let go of that adhesion okay it's
on the inside of his arm so let's say uh
he tries to go forward I take it into
the circle
so for example he's trying to go forward
get right back into the circle there's a
forward pressure on it okay now here he
tries to get up that's what I want
that's what takes him into the technique
okay
I'm gonna come around
second part I'd like for you to get
is this elbow like all the other
Catholic Atomic has to go on the front
side
can't go on the back side
that's not going to work
you're going to be strong you're not
going to get it has to go on the front
side
so you have to work that in
oh this has to go on the front side
there it is right there
can't be two moves
front side there it is on the front
foreign
on the front
get the adhesion on the front side
I don't want to be in the joint I don't
want to cut the joint I'm using the
joint lock to be in his Center
in his Center
okay so sanction is no different
when I come around here I don't want to
turn I'm not trying to turn this and
stay in the joint
like using the joint lock
to put it in his
body this way
so don't turn here
hold there and that goes in his body so
I have to find a way of taking energy
from here
of his arm and into his Center hits his
body that's what makes him move it's
still in his body it's still there
still there
so I'm gonna go around that energy and
that's when it to push on me you see
it's there I'm gonna get out of the way
of this and cut it down
cool
the more you twist his wrist the
stronger you have to be
so if all your things about hurting him
he's stronger than me here don't hurt my
thumb because he's jacked up just do it
slowly
untwist
so I'm gonna have to do it here now do
you see and he's still stronger than me
do his love don't hurt me there you go
you see but instead I'm in his body
you see that difference I'm not in the
wrist fix yourself
[Music]
you all right yeah
foreign
get out of the wrist
cannot smell the spinned and go to the
pin okay so when you're here like this
it's not going to be
shove him down push down
you're going to use an inverse spiral of
Eco to get him down so that's why I need
him to go that way
I'm going to cut down
don't smell this pin it's not there
I'm gonna break take this elbow control
now and keep him turning around
then they'll fall
Okay so
what I'm seeing is you have one more 10
cotton do
huh
in the hands one
two one more tank on I'm gonna bring him
this way
cool
into him one two not enough don't smell
that one around again
thank you
that's what helps his elbow get on the
front side of me
I'll show two hand transition details in
the version we're doing okay so we'll we
have the first part
this far here okay
so
this comes here this little takeover
there there you have your elbow control
I'm going to go inside and go to that
adhesion control
then they'll have a fulcrum here in
between this fulcrum
and this elbow control I can turn my
hands
turn my hand and grab his fingers
that's the first thing there's not don't
grab song kill yet I cannot get song
killed don't grab song kill here
transition
to their
there is your song kill when he comes up
and I let him up okay
so again
here in place
turn don't come off
turn around
take his pinky push it behind that'll
have your smaller hands will work just
fine
here those finger locks are helping the
energy go into him
so don't have it here
you need to put those finger locks in a
place where the energy can go into him
to grip the sanctule
there it is right there
so again you got here
boom there's adhesion on the arm
boom
adhesion roll around in place
don't lose contact
again
right here
stand up nope
stand up nope stand up nope stand up
nope
okay doesn't mean he can't stand up
because I keep those adhesions in place
next one we finished
okay and we're gonna come around
here is the PIN okay that the elbow goes
in place and you can see how
mechanically awkward that is
so
open up this finger
put your chest on his hand
and this hand comes up and puts his hand
on your chest so you're here you can see
how I would be here right it's going to
get very awkward that's very awkward so
before it gets awkward I change Hans I'm
in the same block same lock
this controls the elbow to give me the
bend to give me the leverage I need so
he has a straight arm you'll come Bend
his elbow you'll get it you can do it
this way
you can do it with the technique key on
but you can't have a straight arm
he'll be too strong
then
so again
you're gonna get here
just open up the finger don't keep going
like that that looks so awkward it is
awkward
here open the finger and replace
here open the finger come underneath
when you grab the song kill
you can see it's still strong kill still
song kill still song killed in place
okay get those two hand transitions
clean them up